she dared to run against the regime
but a day later she was on the run
herself
forced to flee belarus scared for her
children
finally emerging from hiding in next
door lithuania
the main opposition leader still nervous
but defiant
i think that every person in our country
uh feels fear and
is scary now but it's our mission to
step
over all our fears and move further
you have become a symbol of this
unprecedented
uprising in your country when are you
going to return
home and are you willing to risk arrest
if alexander lukashenko remains in power
i love my country very much and i want
back there and i will return there when
i feel safe there
we want what every person in the world
is entitled to
a right to live a right to be safe in
the street
a right not to be imprisoned without a
fair trial
and the right to fair free and
transparent elections
her cause has inspired days of
unprecedented protests against
26 years of strongman rule
but no sign of surrender from the
president doubling down on descent
four days ago many people would say well
they have
their original villains in the week and
right now many people
think that actually it will take several
months or several years
but what is important right now is that
actually majority of villarsons
made their decision and it's very clear
that lukashenko will leave
just not immediately this man's
part of an opposition council set up to
oversee a transfer of power
instead threatened with prosecution
new protests planned for this weekend a
key test of nerves
the ibrahim sky news vilnius